Hold onto your hats, true believers.
While Marvel Studios Phase 4 is pretty much
set in stone, and Phase 5 is only beginning
to take shape, the rumor mill has churned
out an eye-popper: the studio is reportedly
prepping an ​Avengers vs. X-Men​ movie,
possibly for Phase 6.
The report comes from our friends at We Got
This Covered, who we know don't always nail
it when it comes to the Marvel pipeline.
But that hasn't stopped them from making this
bold claim about the future of the MCU.
Citing inside sources, the publication put
forth a surprising number of details about
the alleged Avengers vs. X-Men project.
"Are you sure you saw what you saw?"
According to these sources the proposed picture
would come down the pike well after the X-Men
have been introduced into the MCU, which is
not expected to happen for two years or more.
It would involve different Avengers from the
ones that we all know and love, which squares
with comments made by Marvel head honcho Kevin
Feige to MTV News back in June.
Feige said at the time,
"[The new Avengers] will be a very different
team than we've seen before; that's what Endgame
was all about.
It will be a very different incarnation of
the team, with some people you've already
met, and some people you haven't met yet."
According to WGTC's sources, the team that
Marvel has in mind fits that description to
a T. Black Panther, Scarlet Witch, and assuming
that Sony and Marvel eventually get around
to ironing out their differences Spider-Man
could all be on board, as well as the Jane
Foster version of Thor, who is set to make
her debut in 2022's Thor: Love and Thunder.
Also up for spots on the team: Simu Liu's
Shang-Chi, whose solo feature Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings drops in February
2021, and Mahershala Ali's Blade, whose solo
movie is thought to be scaring up Phase 5.
Even more intriguingly, the flick is said
to be taking the inspiration for its plot
from a mind-blowing Marvel storyline: House
of M. The 2005 crossover event, penned by
comics legend Brian Michael Bendis, mostly
took place in an alternate reality created
by Scarlet Witch after she suffered a mental
breakdown.
But most notably, Wanda also used her reality-altering
abilities to depower virtually every mutant
on Earth.
Not in the alternate reality, but in the actual
Marvel U.
The events of House of M had a lasting effect
on the Marvel universe, and elements of the
story led into the 2012 Avengers vs. X-Men
crossover, also co-written by Bendis.
Obviously, a good number of tweaks would have
to be made to adapt the story to the screen,
but this is nothing new for Marvel; Captain
America: Civil War took a ton of liberties
with the 2006-2007 event from which it took
its title, just as the one-two punch of Avengers:
Infinity War and Avengers: Endgame did with
1991's Infinity Gauntlet limited series.
While the news of a potential Avengers vs.
X-Men movie might sound like a whole lot of
wishful thinking, it's worth mentioning that
the very same sources that supplied WGTC with
the intel have been right on the money with
their Marvel rumor-mongering on multiple occasions.
They had previously leaked that the real Mandarin
would be the villain of Shang-Chi and the
Ten Rings, that the post-credits scene in
the Avengers: Endgame re-release would center
on the Hulk, and that iconic Marvel baddie
the Taskmaster would be the primary antagonist
of next year's Black Widow; all of these reports
turned out to be accurate, so while they may
be wrong sometimes, these folks do seem to
have managed to sneak a few top secret files
out of Marvel Studios' offices under their
trenchcoats.
We may not yet know exactly how Mighty Marvel
will approach folding the X-Men into the MCU
or how its take will differ from the long-running
Fox Studios X-Men film series, but we're going
to go ahead and state the obvious: an Avengers
vs. X-Men flick has the potential to be nothing
short of epic.
If we ever do get a formal announcement, the
force of fans' heads all around the world
exploding will register on the Richter scale.
Obviously, Marvel loves to keep details about
its upcoming films and television series close
to the vest, meaning that even if Avengers
vs. X-Men is being actively developed, we're
not going to hear anything official about
it for a long, long time.
"They can threaten me all they want, Charles.
I'll never tell them where you are."
But you'd better believe that we'll be keeping
our eyes peeled for all the latest rumors
and leaks.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.